der Airport Frankfurt ist der größte
Flughafen in Deutschland von hier aus
starten täglich viele Flugzeuge in die
ganze Welt hinaus darunter auch sehr
viele Langstreckenflieger ich habe mir
als Aufgabe gesetzt spontan zum
Flughafen zu steppen und den
erstmöglichen Langstreckenflug zu buchen
es erwartet euch eine spannende Zeit mit
Videos von mir ganz alleine auf der
anderen Seite der Welt viel Spaß
[Musik]
und damit jo Leute was geht herzlich
willkommen zu einem Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's allen gut befinde
mich hier gerade wie man sehen kann noch
in meiner Wohnung allerdings geht's
jetzt gleich zum Flughafen man muss halt
auch sagen in Deutschland ist das Wetter
unfassbar geil zur Zeit und ich fliege
jetzt irgendwo anders hin muss
hoffentlich noch besser ist und ich muss
auch sagen ich bin wirklich etwas nervös
weil es geht unfassbar weit weg war noch
nie alleine so weit weg ich weiß auch
nicht wie lange wann ich wieder da bin
keine Ahnung ich habe jetzt wirklich in
der letzten Zeit viele Orte gesehen war
auch immer alleine unterwegs und das
ging auch immer klar aber das ist ja
jetzt schon so ein bisschen next level
weil man halt einfach keine Ahnung
könnte halt sein dass ich 15 oder 20
Stunden irgendwo hinfliege das einzige
was ich dabei habe ist mein Rucksack
hier und mein Reisepass der ist ganz
wichtig den brauche ich ist ja klar
eigentlich hatte ich sogar auch erst vor
also wir haben jetzt heute Samstag ich
wollte erst Montag das ganze starten
also übermorgen ich dachte mir jetzt
okay ich habe heute eigentlich nichts
geplant morgen auch nichts geplant dann
fahre jetzt einfach zum Flughafen ich
fahre jetzt nach Frankfurt das ja der
größte Flughafen in Deutschland Vater
ungefähr drei Stunden Zug hin und dann
schauen wir mal wo es hin ich kriege
schon ich will auch nicht übertreiben
okay aber ich kriege bisschen Gänsehaut
also wir machen es auf jeden Fall wieder
wie beim letzten Mal der erste Flug
erste Langstreckenflug diesmal auf der
Anzeigetafel ich hoffe die haben das da
irgendwie getrennt Langstreckenflüge
sind woanders das wäre halt besser sonst
ist ein bisschen Kuddel den buchig
fliegt dahin natürlich gibt's ein paar
Voraussetzungen ich muss ja halt
einreisen können also wenn man kein Visa
schnell bekommen kann für das jeweilige
Land dann fällt das schon mal raus und
wenn da jetzt irgendwie gefährliche
Krankheiten oder so herrschen wo ich
mich besser hätte vorher impfen sollen
dann ist das auch raus also das muss ich
mir vorher anschauen ich denke das
sollte für jeden verständlich sein
anders geht's halt nicht ja ich habe
wirklich nicht viele Sachen dabei mal
gucken wie lange ich damit auskomme ich
versuche dann natürlich auch dort vor
Ort noch einige Videos zu machen und Wir
labern jetzt gar nicht mehr lange und
fahren jetzt erstmal zum Bahnhof Leute
let's go es wird ein geiles Video so
Leute mein Bruder bringt mich jetzt zum
Bahnhof danke erstmal was glaubst du
denn wie lange bin ich unterwegs komme
am Ende der Welt okay Leute ich bin
jetzt gerade in Essen am Hauptbahnhof
und von hier aus nehme ich jetzt zur
nächsten Zug nach Frankfurt und dann bin
ich um 15 Uhr ungefähr dort am Flughafen
dann schauen wir mal wie es weiter geht
okay Leute angekommen in Frankfurt am
Flughafen wenn es doch schon 16 Uhr ich
hatte eine Dreiviertelstunde Verspätung
aber nichts machen ja und jetzt schaue
ich mal wie es weitergeht okay Leute ich
muss jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal
irgendeine Anzeigetafel finden Punkte
ist ja wirklich ziemlich riesig deswegen
ich glaube so ein bis zwei Kilometer zu
Fuß jetzt erstmal weil ich bin ja gerade
noch am Bahnhof hier und dann schauen
wir mal wer halt super wenn ich auch in
den nächsten zwei drei Stunden losfliege
weil ja viel früher dass du besser jetzt
ist hier schon direkt die Frage gehe ich
zu Terminal 1 oder 2a und Z das was oben
steht ist ja meistens das größte
deswegen gehen wir jetzt hier lang
also ich muss definitiv jetzt erstmal
eine Anzeigetafel finden weil okay da
unten ist eine schauen wir uns das mal
an okay Leute ich habe die Anzeigetafel
gefunden man muss sagen das ist hier auf
jeden Fall noch ziemlich altmodisch aber
ich finde es geil also nicht so digital
und wenn man hier mal hoch schaut Alter
das sind echt extrem viele Flüge fahren
es geht noch von 16 Uhr gerade bis dahin
17:50 Uhr also bestimmt über 50 Flüge in
den nächsten eineinhalb Stunden und es
sind auch Langstreckenflüge und
kurzstreckenflügel gemischt das wird
jetzt auf jeden Fall höchst interessant
daran vernünftigen Flug rauszufinden den
ich nehmen kann also den ersten nicht
gefunden habe da steht LH 4004 nach New
York Lufthansa und da drunter noch mal
United Airways Washington Dallas also
bis jetzt eigentlich nur Amerika da ist
noch San Francisco Boston casablan haben
wir auch noch 18:10 Uhr mehr Langstrecke
stehen da nicht drauf ich muss mich mal
kurz irgendwo hinsetzen und ein bisschen
checken weil mich gucken hier alle auch
schon ziemlich dumm an das Ding ist halt
auch nur USA braucht man immer Visum und
wenn man Glück hat bekommt man das
zweieinhalb von zwei Stunden ich war
schon mal ist aber keine Garantie also
die gehen immer an es kann auch bis zu
24 Stunden dauern ich weiß nicht ganz
genau deswegen ich schaue jetzt mal okay
beste Stativ kleinen Moment jetzt
solltet ihr mich auf jeden Fall gut
sehen können also schauen wir mal rein
ich würde direkt sagen Amerika fällt
eigentlich weg weil das ist mir ein
bisschen zu risky nachher kriege ich das
Visum nicht in der kurzen Zeit und dann
ist die Flugbuchung für ein Arsch
deswegen lieber irgendwas wo ich am
besten ohne Visum mit meinem deutschen
Reisepass einreisen kann das gibt's halt
auch viel Casablanca ach so das ist ja
marokko ist ja gar kein Langstrecke
zumindest nicht so wirklich das fällt
raus okay Geographie nicht so aufgepasst
ich hätte wirklich gedacht es fliegen
noch mehr verschiedene Langstreckenflüge
in die ganze Welt hinaus von Frankfurt
als anstatt fast nur halt Amerika
deswegen ähm ich habe jetzt noch die
zwei Stunden nach 17:50 Uhr bis zu dem
Zeitpunkt zu dem Zeit auf der
Anzeigetafel geht muss ich mal kurz
hinlegen also ich habe jetzt noch online
da kann man natürlich noch weiter
schauen als das was da auf der
Anzeigetafel steht und da kommen noch
ihr könnt hier sehen ein paar weitere
Flüge zum Beispiel nach Soul um 18:30
Uhr ja das merken wir uns schon mal dass
wir echt auch will weil ich war noch nie
so ein Asien das war jetzt auch nie so
mein das Ziel aber ja ich würde es
machen was ist das denn Masa Alarm wo
ist denn das oh Ägypten da war ja
letztens eine hyattacke okay es ist auch
ist das Langstrecke also ist auf jeden
Fall keine krasse Langstrecke ich glaube
der beste in 5 Stunden 19:40 Uhr Tokio
ui ui auch krass 20:15 Uhr Peking 20:40
Uhr Bangkok zu wannabumi 20:50 Uhr mit
Lufthansa nach vorne kommen okay also
ich habe mir das jetzt alles mal gemerkt
einer davon werde ich aber nehmen können
da hat mir mal mit Soul ob der noch
verfügbar ist das wäre schon in zwei
Stunden heute ist Samstag auf 700 €.
okay das sind auf jeden Fall beides
nicht die nonstop Flüge also der ist
leider weg dann hatten wir noch Tokio
wobei ich mir da auch nicht sicher bin
wegen Visum auch weg aber warte mal hat
mir jetzt glaube ich noch bankkopf
Thailand
okay
20:40 Uhr 493 Euro
economy Bangkok Alter also ohne Scheiß
Bangkok war nie so eins meiner
Traumziele ich verbinde Bangkok mit
einer absoluten Turbo stressige Stadt
die ist ja auch verdammt groß und ich
hasse große Städte aber das wäre
zumindest jetzt der erste den ich buchen
können jetzt muss ich noch gucken ob ich
da überhaupt einreisen darf auch kein
Visum okay das ist schon mal gut und wie
ist das mit Impfung wenn ich da jetzt
irgendwie
bangkok-impfung Impfungen ja okay das
habe ich ja Tollwut hatte ich letztens
da bin ich immun gegen deswegen ich
versuche den jetzt einfach zu buchen
let's go und dann geht's nach Bangkok
Digger es ist einfach so verstrahlt
wirklich muss ich noch meine Mama
schreiben dass ich nach Bangkok Fliege
die wird sich freuen let's go
okay Leute Flug ist gebucht und ich habe
auch schon meine Bordkarte hier hat
jetzt 490 € gekostet ich habe auch
direkt über drei Airways gebucht hier
könnt ihr sehen Boarding ist um 20 Uhr
also erst in vier Stunden ich weiß noch
nicht genau ob ich damit überhaupt schon
durch den Security checke komme das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an und der
Flug dauert 10 Stunden 50 also entspannt
wird das nicht aber ich werde schon
überstehen
geil
[Musik]
danke Ciao Security Check war auf jeden
Fall sehr entspannt hier ist erstaunlich
wenn ich los zumindest jetzt an dem
Terminal wo ich bin Gott sei Dank habe
ich meine MX deswegen kann ich jetzt
erstmal die Lounge gehen die suchen wir
mal und dann muss ich auch noch vier
Stunden warten okay Leute zu früh
gefreut die Lounge tue ich hätte
hingehen können ist vom Security Check
ich bin schon drin habe ich irgendwie
verpeilt jetzt muss ich hier was essen
aber egal es gibt ja auch Lufthansa
Landes aber da habe ich keinen Access zu
könnte ich mir kaufen aber kostet 60 €
oder dachte ich mir jetzt ist Quatsch
weil hier sehe nichts los wobei ist für
das Video sicherlich ganz cool weil ihr
könnt ja mal dann nach oben da lassen
wir nicht mal öfter so launches oder so
testen soll es ab okay falsch aber hier
ist mein Flug Bangkok 4 Minuten 64 46 so
rum let's go hey es ist einfach viel zu
groß hier
alle Leute ich bin gerade noch am warten
und das ist auch mein Flugzeug glaube
ich zumindest also müsste das jetzt sein
was heute noch von Teil Airways hier
abfliegt ja schön
so Leute ab zum Boarding ich habe mir
noch einen Nackenkissen gekauft jetzt
geht's los
ich freue mich hihi ich habe auf jeden
Fall sitzt 49a und ich glaube der
Flieger ist auch ziemlich leer
[Musik]
für Business Class hat heute leider
nicht gereicht naja Rückflug
Nackenkissen hatte ich mir auch sparen
können also bis jetzt auf jeden Fall
ganze Reihe für mich hoffentlich bleibt
das so das wäre gut aber wahrscheinlich
nicht also ich hatte auch schon mal mehr
Platz auf dem Langstreckenflug aber egal
okay
wenn ich das hier alles für mich habe
bitte okay also wir sind gerade hier man
kann zu lesen wo ist ja schon mal ganz
gut
[Musik]
gestanden hatte gar keinen Plan wo ich
am nächsten Tag 24 Stunden sein werde
und jetzt weiß ich es ist Bangkok okay
wie gesagt ich weiß noch überhaupt nicht
wie lange ich da bleiben werde aber ich
muss ja schon ein bisschen da bleiben
oder gucken was da noch so geht weil
sonst würde ich das ja gar nicht weit
weg
[Musik]
okay so sieht das Essen aus wir schicken
mit Reis keine Ahnung was das ist
das sind runter
irgendwelche Crackers
könnte schlimmer sein alles gut
so Leute wir haben jetzt mittlerweile 23
Uhr deutscher Zeit ich war gerade noch
kurz auf Klo das ganze Flugzeug ist
jetzt dunkel das ist richtig lecker also
überraschenderweise ja hat mir richtig
gut geschmeckt hätte ich nicht gedacht
ich kann auch die ganze Zeit so Getränke
bestellen und das ist wohl normal auf
Langstreckenflügen das ist alles umsonst
ist obwohl ich ja nur ich konnte aber
jetzt gehen wir erstmal schlafen weil
alle anderen schlafen das Gute ist
komplett dunkel und dann bin ich so in
ca 8 Stunden da freue ich mich
[Musik]
guten Morgen Ich habe vier Stunden
geschlafen
ja
man muss echt sagen die Landschaften von
hier oben sehen super krass aus habe ich
noch nie gesehen bevor das ist alles
guck mal die Felder sind hier so
länglich crazy
und das ist halt wirklich auch alles
künstlich verändert worden also sieht
alles aus wie gemalt
[Musik]
so Leute ich bin auf jeden Fall da jetzt
erstmal zur Einreise Kontrolle ich hoffe
das klappt alles so wie es mir vorstelle
weil in diesem wäre ganz gut abreißen
aber es wird schon und dann müssen wir
noch ein Hotel buchen das habe ich auch
noch nicht es bleibt spannend okay Leute
sehr gut ich habe es geschafft ich sehe
echt ziemlich fertig aus ne als süße
das Gute ist sogar wenn man deutschen
Pass hat ich stand erst in seiner Visa
Einreise Dingsbums hätte da irgendwie 20
Minuten warten müssen das braucht Dich
gar nicht ich kann einfach durchrennen
die haben mir 30 Tage Visum gegeben kann
ich euch gleich mal zeigen und jetzt
kann ich hier erstmal 30 Tage entspannen
aber ich denke solange wir jetzt nicht
Hotel habe ich online gesehen aber noch
nicht gebucht ich fahre jetzt einfach
hin weil dann ist es vielleicht
günstiger schauen wir mal
[Musik]
jetzt brauche ich erstmal ein Taxi und
Geld habe ich auch schon gewechselt also
bis jetzt läuft alles sehr gut ich habe
zwar wenig Schlaf aber egal Alter ist
das warm wow
ich habe gar nicht drüber nachgedacht
Bangkok ist eine der heißesten Städte
der Welt das merkt man
Junge ist das warm ey hier sind bestimmt
35 Grad
und ich schaue jetzt mal ob meine
Historie abgezogen zu werden weitergeht
oder ob das hier nicht so ist wir werden
sehen
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall nach Linksverkehr das
wusste ich auch nicht und schaut mal
Leute es ist bewölkt wir haben 31 Grad
das Wetter die nächsten Tage sieht auch
nicht so gut aus aber schauen wir mal
was wird
okay Leute wir müssen auf jeden Fall das
Geld bei meinem Hotel sein das ist echt
heftig also ich wusste natürlich dass es
jetzt nicht allzu teuer ist aber das
Taximeter zeigt gerade 199 Baht an das
sind umgerechnet nicht mal 4 € glaube
ich nee nicht mal sechs Euro so rum und
wir sind schon 25 Minuten unterwegs also
das ist schon crazy aber ich bin jetzt
erstmal aufs Hotel gespannt und ich
hoffe die haben noch ein Zimmer für mich
[Musik]
auch sehr interessant man fährt hier auf
jeden Fall Taxi und schaut nebenbei
Hochheim Videos ich kann jetzt nicht äh
die genaue Plattform sagen weil sonst
versteht er dass ich darüber rede
bisschen gefährlich Kollegah wir stecken
hier allerdings mittlerweile auch schon
voll im Verkehr aber das habe ich auch
nicht anders erwartet man wird hier auf
jeden Fall wirklich komplett in der
andere Welt geschmissen aber das wollte
ich auch heute geht bestimmt noch
einiges denke ich handelt
[Musik]
Aschen will
Aufzug das war das erste mal in meinem
ganzen Leben dass ich im Hotel mehr
bezahlt habe als ich hätte online buchen
können also ich habe jetzt ungefähr 15 €
hier mehr bezahlt umgerechnet echt also
hätte ich niemals gedacht vor mir nicht
okay wir sind da schauen wir uns mal das
Zimmer 818
auf jeden Fall ein sehr sehr schönes
Hotel muss man sagen WOW crazy
das muss das sein
[Musik]
hallo kurz roomtour ich habe zwar auch
noch nicht gesehen wow chillig hier kann
man sogar baden Dusche
ziemlich viele Spiegel großes Bett und
schauen uns mal den Ausblick an das ist
jetzt auch das erste Mal dass ich so
wirklich was sehe von Bangkok okay krass
wow
ja Klimaanlage im Zimmer sehr sehr
wichtig weil es ist so heiß draußen
endlich angekommen ich bin ziemlich müde
ich würde mich gerne noch zwei Stunden
hinlegen weil ich habe heute Nacht
wirklich richtig schlecht geschlafen im
Flugzeug das ganze Flugzeug war gefühlt
krank und hat gehustet ach hier unten
ist sogar ein Fußballstadion geil auf
jeden Fall habe ich mich gestern bevor
ich losgeflogen bin natürlich auch noch
ein bisschen informiert mir so ein paar
Tipps online bei tiktok und so
reingezogen zum Thema Bangkok erste Mal
da und so und da hieß es halt auch
Hotels sind jetzt nicht so teuer auf
jeden Fall coole Hotels aussuchen das
wird sich lohnen deswegen bin ich jetzt
auch hier gelernt das habe ich bei
tiktok gesehen hier gibt's auch so eine
nice Dachterrasse schon mal später mal
an und für diese interessiert das Hotel
heißt längste habe ich eben schon gesagt
der Tag war das nicht verstanden lag
wahrscheinlich an meine Aussprache
irgendwann hat das dann doch gecheckt
auf jeden Fall hätte das Online 90 €
kostet pro Nacht was 55 Sterne Hotel
natürlich in Deutschland ziemlich
günstig wäre ich habe jetzt umgerechnet
glaube ich 105 € oder so bezahlt oder
110 keine Ahnung Massage gibt's auch
schnell Massage 1000 Watt ne ich bin
aber mittlerweile jetzt auch schon seit
22 Stunden unterwegs deswegen oh
jetzt mal ausruhen bis später kurz
geschlafen und jetzt habe ich mich hier
mal eben in meinen Badeanzug geschmissen
Badeanzug nee das hier im Bademantel wir
haben jetzt auch schon 18 Uhr und hier
geht's sogar um 18:30 Uhr aktuell die
Sonne unter sie ist schon ziemlich weit
unten was mir eben aufgefallen ist hier
direkt unter meinem Hotel da unten Leben
Leute ne also hier sind Hotels und da
wurden welche echt crazy da fährt eine
Bahn lang ja gut ich bin mal gespannt
was für Eindrücke ich gleich noch
zusammen werde aber wir gehen jetzt
erstmal diesen Pool abchecken weil der
soll ganz cool sein sieht auch nice
Bilder ich hoffe da kann ich einfach
hingehen genau bestimmt schauen wir mal
machen so Leute oben angekommen hier
gibt's auch ein Geisteskranken großes
Fitnessstudio ich habe noch nie so ein
großes fitnessstudien im Hotel gesehen
und da vorne ist der geil view cool oder
wieder heißt Sonntag glaube ich so wow
da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
Leute schaut euch das mal an hier
einfach der Pool
und diese geile Aussicht
rein
[Musik]
genau was mir noch eingefallen ist
könnte nämlich für Missverständnis
Sorgen ich habe immer gesagt ich muss
noch mein Visum bekommen ich musste
allerdings einfach nur durch die
Einreisekontrolle und konnte mir so ein
Stempel abholen aber das ist ja quasi
mein Visum jetzt für 30 Tage ich zeig's
euch mal eben so sieht das aus das hat
der Breder drauf geklatscht also ich
müsste jetzt am 10 Juli raus aber ich
werde mal stark davon ausgehen dass ich
bis dahin halt nicht mehr hier bin es
sei denn natürlich ich treffe Julian
zieht los und ich habe gesehen hier
gibt's eine Minibar mit aha dann können
wir die Aufgabe mich auch schon
erledigen local thailändisches original
Thai Bier Bangkok Thailand ja siehst
immer vor meinem Hotel fährt einfach Zug
warte wo ist er da unten ach so da fährt
einer genau und hier oben fährt auch
noch eine Bahn dann und das ist echt
laut hast du auch Bock endlich nicht
mehr Nein zu feiern Arbeit zu müssen und
von überall auf der Welt zu arbeiten
dann komm jetzt in die Gruppe Youtube
Videos machen damit geht's okay wir
probieren mal
ja aber Leute an der Stelle auch mal
mega großes Dankeschön das kann man ja
auch eigentlich nicht oft genug sagen
ich habe jetzt in den letzten zwei
Monaten wirklich unfassbar viel erlebt
und mir macht es richtig viel Spaß
wieder diese Youtube Videos zu
produzieren so viel Spaß hatte ich ganz
lange nicht ganz früher natürlich mal
aber irgendwann ging das bei mir so ein
bisschen schleppend bergab aber ich bin
in letzter Zeit wirklich fast zu 100%
glücklich und vor allem diese
beruflichen Sachen sind echt geil also
da kann man nicht oft genug danke sagen
dass ihr mir das ermöglicht quasi dass
ich Zuschauer habe die sich das
reinziehen und ich halt reisen kann und
damit Geld verdiene ist schon sehr sehr
Welt also vielen Dank an jeden einzelnen
von euch an dieser Stelle mal der das
schaut danke und wir gehen jetzt äh in
die Stadt okay Leute geduscht und
umgezogen ich hoffe ich bin nicht zu
warm angezogen bin jetzt schon am
schwitzen auf jeden Fall gerade schon
ein paar Sachen hochgeladen wir gehen
jetzt aber erstmal raus ich bin echt mal
gespannt ich weiß natürlich was hier so
abgeht
schauen wir mal wie das so in echt alles
aussieht okay Leute ich habe mich
spontan dazu entschieden einen kleinen
Drink hier in der Skype vom Hotel zu
nehmen kann man ja auch nicht nein sagen
mit dieser phänomenalen Aussicht und
danach stürzt sie uns irgendwo da hinten
rein ich weiß halt noch nicht vor weil
das ist ziemlich groß oder halt auch da
das sieht so krank aus hier wirklich
mehr wenn man das in echt sehen könnte
wow ich muss sagen ich finde es echt
super dass ich hier gelandet bin wobei
faul oder sowas ich glaube diese
asiatischen Großstädte sind alle super
krass okay Leute
ich bin jetzt auf dem streets unterwegs
erstmal müssen wir jetzt hier rüber aber
ich glaube das juckt hier keiner das
hier in Zebrastreifen ist was mache ich
jetzt okay ich gehe jetzt einfach nee
[Musik]
ich werde so überlaufen gebrettert
run
okay erste Hürde geschafft und
[Musik]
okay hat das funktioniert ich gehe auf
jeden Fall jetzt noch Sushi essen das
wollte ich äh hier machen auch wenn
Sushi glaube ich eigentlich aus Japan
kommt sorry dass es zu laut ist ich habe
jetzt auch meine Hauptkamera nicht mit
und dann gehen wir mal hier in diese
Party malen und schau mal was da so geht
aber erstmal muss ich auf jeden Fall was
essen ich habe schon ziemlich lange
nicht vergessen übrigens eine Frage noch
und zwar meinte wir am Flugzeug das bei
Thai Airways die Leute in der Bus ist
das gleiche Essen bekommen wie die Leute
die Economy fliegen
auf jeden Fall meinte jemand die Leute
in der Business Class bekommen das
gleiche Essen wie wir nur halt anders
angerichtet und ich hatte für Business
Class 800 € mehr zahlen müssen also
hätte sich ja gar nicht gelohnt nur für
ein bisschen mehr liegen oder so könnt
ihr mal kommentieren falls ihr das wisst
und ja hey wie crazy einfach alles voll
mit so Stromkabel ich gehe jetzt mal
hier besser über die Straße da muss ich
mich nicht direkt wieder ein
Lebensgefahr geben also das ist wirklich
eine kranke Stadt
also Leute hier hinter mir ist einfach
dieser Sushi laden aber der hat jetzt
anscheinend schon zu wie soll man den
bitte finden da steht ja nicht mal ein
Schild dran oh mann na ja jetzt muss ich
weitersuchen ich habe so hunger ne und
ich bin absolut verloren bei Google
stand das ja noch auf hat bis 22:30 Uhr
wir haben auch erst 20 Uhr es fühlt sich
auch sowieso so an als hätten wir
eigentlich schon 23 Uhr weil es schon so
dunkel ist jetzt muss ich mal gucken wo
ich was zu essen finde ey okay Leute ich
bin einfach zum Supermarkt hier gibt's
auf jeden Fall coole Sachen und ziemlich
günstig ja cool gibt's in Deutschland
auch weil die Restaurants schließen ja
auch irgendwie ziemlich früh und bevor
ich jetzt gar nicht was zu essen bekomme
wollte ich mir hier mal erstmal was auch
mal kurz was negatives okay es ist eine
Großstadt aber überall liegt hier Müll
rum ich esse jetzt erstmal mein
Croissant richtig lecker schön zu
Abendbrot Croissant weil ich nichts
anderes finde ich Vollidiot also an
jeder Kreuzung kommt ein richtiger
Gestank entgegen aber okay das ist
natürlich in New York oder so auch so
aber hier fällt einem das schon extrem
auf ey einfach an dem Zebrastreifen
durch gerade eben rüber gerannt wenn es
jetzt ein Unfall passiert ich hoffe
nichts schlimmes ey aber die fahren ja
auch alle als hätten die absolut einen
Weg ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt
gegessen
auf jeden Fall super viele verschiedene
kleinere Party Bezirke in Bangkok
bestimmt über 20 und ich habe jetzt
einfach den genommen der bei mir am
nächsten war ich gestern ungefähr 3
Kilometer ich will ja auch ein bisschen
was sehen hier und ja vielleicht fahre
ich dann mit Taxi zurück schauen wir mal
bis gleich
ich weiß auch nicht so ganz
ob ich diesen Ständen vertrauen kann auf
jeden Fall bin ich jetzt da schauen wir
mal
[Musik]
ich wurde die ganze Zeit angepasst ich
musste ganz schnell weg auf jeden Fall
also ich werde schon
[Musik]
ich will doch nur in Ruhe ein Bierchen
trinken aber ich muss ja nicht dass das
hier so abgeht
oder so trinken und die ganze Zeit an
meinem T-Shirt und so gezogen und die
wollten halt dass sie mich massieren
oder
so muss ich sagen
[Musik]
so ich bin auf jeden Fall jetzt erstmal
im Bett erster Tag Bangkok war super
stressig wir halten fest eine extrem
große Stadt ich würde mal sagen ich habe
jetzt vielleicht so ein 200 gesehen
vielleicht sogar noch weniger es ist
wirklich extrem heiß also selbst jetzt
heute abend wir haben gerade noch 28
Grad und es ist 11:30 Uhr und die
Luftfeuchtigkeit ist so enorm hoch
dadurch stinkt auch der ganze Müll der
von diesen kleinen street food Ständen
auf die Straße geschmissen wird also ich
habe wirklich an so vielen Stellen so
richtig bestialischen Geruch gerochen
das habe ich vorher noch nie gerochen
und wenn man Party machen will wird man
die ganze Zeit irgendwo hingezogen zu
einer Massage gut vielleicht hatte ich
jetzt auch einfach nur Pärchen im
Partyviertel wo ich da war trotzdem die
Leute sind super freundlich und haben
alle Lächeln auf dem Gesicht das ist mir
aufgefallen und ja an sich ist schon
eine coole Stadt aber ich werde jetzt
auf jeden Fall nicht länger aushalten
ich muss hier weg das ist mir einfach
viel zu turbulant Leute ich würde sagen
dieses Video beende ich hier abonniert
super gerne den Kanal für weitere
reisevideos und lassen dann nach oben da
und wir sehen uns dann nächste Woche
wieder da gibt's ein neues Video mal
schauen wo ich landen werde also ich
werde natürlich noch weiterreisen wir
bestimmt geil ich freue mich schon
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen danke für den
Sport checkt auch die letzten Videos ab
haut rein Leute ciao